right now congratulations are in order  for Rachel vice and Daniel Craig the two  are expecting their first child together  the notoriously pride the couple out in  New York today after the announcement  the 48 year old covering any sign of a  baby bump in a blue trench coat  Rachel confirming the surprising news to  the New York Times quote I'll be showing  soon Daniel and I are so happy we're  going to have a little human just  feeling being happy and having a really  wonderful family vais already has an  eleven year-old son Henry with director  Darren Aronofsky while Craig has a  twenty five-year-old daughter from his  first marriage  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]